hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
human hematopoietic stem cell research
made smart and easy i am michelle ashton
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by miltoni biotek to
learn more visit miltonibbiotech.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker anja
pramar
the global product manager of
regenerative medicine
at miltoni biotech for a complete
biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top
of your screen anya you may now begin
your
presentation welcome
thank you very much for the kind
introduction michelle and welcome
everyone from my site so my name is
anticlima
and i'm working as a global product
manager at miltoni biotech
as part of the regenerative medicine
team i'm managing the hematopoietic stem
cell product portfolio
and today i'm very happy to talk about
human hematopoietic
stem cell research and how to make it
smart
and easy this is the disclaimer of my
presentation
at first i will give you a short
introduction
which leads us to the topic of today the
human hematopoietic stem cell
hsc research for human hsc research we
are going to talk about the isolation
the culture and the analysis of human
agencies
so let's start
what are stem cells all stem cells share
two main properties
which are self-renewal and potency
self-renewal leads to
cells that have the same properties at
the mother cell
so in a very easy way to say stem cell
renewal describes a process
by which stem cells divide to make more
stem cells
potency is the ability to differentiate
into a more specialized cell
this can either be a cell of a certain
tissue or
a stem cell with less potential than the
mother stem cell
the level of potency defines the type of
stem cell
according to the stem cell
differentiation ability
there are different levels of potency
total potency is the ability of a single
cell to divide and produce
all of the differentiated cells in an
organism
one example for a totipotent stem cell
is the zygote
which is formed by the fertilization
event
in contrast blurry protein stem cells
can only differentiate
into embryonic cells so blurry potency
refers to a stem cell that has the
potential to differentiate into all cell
types
that derive from the three embryonic
germ layers
the endoderm the mesoderm or the
ectoderm
based on the origin blurry protein stem
cells can be classified as embryonic
stem cells
short escs or induced blurry potent stem
cells
short iprc's multipotencies
describe stem cells with the potential
to differentiate into discrete cell
types
multipotent stem cells are for example
mesenchymal stem cells
short embassies or hematopoietic stem
cells
short hscs today we are going to learn
more about
human agencies as multipotent stem cells
hscs are tissue-specific adult stem
cells
which can differentiate into all blood
cell types
simply the process of blood cell
formation is called hematopoiesis
it occurs in the hematopoietic system
which includes
organs and tissues such as the bone
marrow the liver and the spleen
the first signs of hematopoiesis occur
during embryonic development
in blood islands within the yolk sac and
in the aorta
gonad misumifis region these early hscs
migrate in light later developmental
stages
into the placenta and the fetal liver
which
serve as the main compartments of
prenatal hematopoiesis
shortly before birth hsc's migrate to
bone marrow
where adult hematopoiesis takes place
throughout life
every day the adult hematopoiesis must
balance an enormous production
as the average person produces more than
500 billion of blood cells
hscs are found typically in the bone
marrow
especially in the pelvis femur and
sternum
besides bone marrow agencies can be
found and
isolated from blood sources such as
umbilical cord blood
buffy code peripheral blood or epheresis
products
depending on the starting material the
atc content varies
etheresis refers to the process of
separating cellular
and soluble components of blood it is a
non-surgical procedure
that means blood is drawn from one arm
and passes through a machine that
collects the stem cells
the remaining portion of the blood is
then returned in the other arm
for mobilized epheresis tracts such as
tivocrestem
mobilizes stem cells from the bone
marrow into the peripheral bloodstream
before the apheresis procedure takes
place
by mobilized etheresis it is possible to
reach higher numbers of hscs
approximately up to two percent
for the hsc researcher the typical
workflow looks like this
routinely hsc containing samples are
processed over density gradient
centrifugation
to pre-enrich mononuclear cells as
starting material for subsequent
isolation of agencies
for the culture and expansion of hscs
it is important to add cytokines to
maintain the differentiation potential
for the analysis of hscs specific
markers are used to define the phenotype
and hsc colony assays are used for
functional analysis
at miltoni we provide products for the
complete workflow of hsvs
by going now through the workflow i will
give you more information
on each topic let's start now
how to make your isolation of hscs smart
and easy
first let's have a look on some
important markers of agencies
and craftsman analysis of hsc
populations
using xenograft models reveal that the
majority of cells migrating
into the recipient's bone marrow express
the surface marker cd34
furthermore these cells lack expression
of linear specific markers
show no or very low expression levels of
cd38
and express markers such as cd 133
and cd 117
for the positive isolation of hscs
the most widely known marker is cd34
it is highly expressed on hscs and to a
lower extent on hematopoietic
progenitors
and early committed cells today i would
like to focus the cd34 enrichment
by our max technology using the cd34
microbeads
our max technology is a column-based
technology for immunomagnetic cell
separation
which is based on antibodies coupled to
magnetic beads
nano sized super paramagnetic max
microbeads
our specific max microbeads are
available for the positive selection of
numerous cell types and cell subsets
here the positive selection for cd34
plus cells
is shown positive selection means
that a particular target cell type is
magnetically labeled
in the first step the cd34 microbeads
are incubated with the cell suspension
during incubation the antibody beep
complex
binds to cells expression the
corresponding epitope cd34
during separation in the second step the
column is placed in the magnetic
field of the max separator then
magnetically labeled cd34 plus cells
are retained within the column whereas
unlabeled cells flow through
after washing step the column is removed
from the magnetic field
and the target cells are looted from the
column
this is shown in step 3.
the separation process can be automated
by using our auto max pro instrument
this automation provides a high level of
standardization
and thus ensures reliable and user
independent results
our max microbeads are biodegradable and
non-toxic
as already mentioned the max microbeads
are conjugated to highly specific
antibodies
against a certain cell surface antigen
they bind specifically to cells
expressing this antigen
and thus preventing non-specific
labeling
due to the low labeling concentrations
and their small size
max microbeads do not lead to activation
of target cells
by these scanning electronic microscopic
images
you can see the proof that our
column-based max technology is gentle to
cells
here on the left side there is no
visible labeling on the cell surface
after cell isolation with max microbeads
and max columns
however here on the right side cells
were isolated by a column 3 technology
from another manufacturer
here you can see excessive labeling
indicated by the white arrows
and this was becoming obvious after
isolation
due to the gentle and effective nature
of the max technology
the isolated cell populations of
interest are highly viable
and pure these isolated cells are
compatible with any downstream
application
for the direct cd34 enrichment by max
technology
i want to introduce two of our products
to you
the cd34 microbead kit allows positive
selection of human agencies and
progenitor cells from various starting
materials
starting materials include peripheral
blood
umbilical cord blood ethyresis harvest
bone marrow
and differentiated embryonic stem cells
and differentiated
induced pluripotent stem cells
those hsc containing samples are first
processed over density gradient
centrifugation
to pre-enrich mononuclear cells a
starting material
for subsequent cd34 enrichment
the same starting materials are
applicable for our cd34 microbead kit
ultrapure
these microbeads have been particularly
optimized for the use with samples
that contain large amounts of cell
debris or low
numbers of target cells they greatly
improve recovery
and purity of the swordhead populations
by specifically enriching viable target
cells
and the cd34 microbead kit ultrapure is
as
easy to use as the classic cd34
microbead kit
here the starting material was
peripheral blood mononuclear cells
short pbmcs the separation was performed
either with the cd34 micro bit kit
on the top or the cd-34 micro bead kit
ultra pure on the bottom shown as the
positive fraction
of the pbmc sample after separation
the comparison of the forward to
sidescatter plot
demonstrates that the classic method the
cd34 microbead kit
cannot avoid the carry over dead cells
or debris when these are present in the
original sample and large amounts
the special formulation of the cd34
microbead cat ultra pure
however avoids this depth we carry over
and results in a much cleaner fraction
after separation
as you see here on the bottom
here you see an example for cd34
separation
from a bone marrow sample the separation
was again performed either with the cd34
micro bit kit
on the top or the cd34 micro bit kit
ultra pure
on the bottom in general cd34 plus
frequencies are higher in bone marrow
than in pbmcs
due to this higher starting frequency
dappy carry over
isn't generally less of a problem with
bone marrow and the difference between
our classic
and the ultra pure kit is less
pronounced
however the data demonstrates that you
can expect the same results
as you have seen from the pbmc sample
again the cd34 microbit kit ultra pure
avoids debris carryover and results in a
cleaner cell population
after separation
here an example of cd34 separation from
quad blood is shown
the separation was again performed
either with the cd34 micro bit kit
on the top or the cd34 mild bit kit
ultra pure on the bottom again the
comparison of the classic c34 micro bit
kit
and the cd34 microbit kit ultra pure
demonstrates the superiority of the cd34
microbead kit ultra pure
with regards to less dappery carryover
as shown by the cleaner cell population
after cd34 enrichment so
please keep in mind for hsc isolation
cd34 is a well established marker for
hcs
our cd34 microbeads allow positive
selection of human hcs
and progenitor cells from various
starting material
the two introduced products allow an
easy one-step isolation of cd34 plus
cells
the cd34 microbead kit ultra pure
is the ideal choice for low frequency
and debris rich samples
as it greatly reduces access of dead
cells and debris carry over
the cd34 microwave kit ultra pure is
as easy to use as the classic cd34
microbead kit
and also suited for all routine
applications
after isolation the hscs needs to be
cultured
for the culture and expansion of hscs it
is important to add cytokines to
maintain the differentiation potential
so let's have a look what is the
smartest way to culture human agencies
the number of hscs in human samples is
often insufficient for downstream
applications
hscs can be expanded in culture with hsc
relevant growth factors
to obtain higher cell numbers or to
study mechanisms
and signalling pathways driving
self-renewal or differentiation
early acting cytokines such as the stem
cell factor
short scf flt3 ligand and thrombopoietin
show tpo expand primitive agencies
also current hsc culture systems
only allow limited expansion and
maintenance of primitive agencies
that are able to uncraft and completely
restore the entire blood system
our stemx hsc expansion system
ensures robust expansion of human hscs
it consists of the stemx hsc expansion
media
xf and the stemx hsc expansion cocktail
the stemmax hsc expansion media is a
sino and serum free medium
specifically formulated for hscs the
stem max
hsc expansion cocktail is an optimized
set of cytokines
which can be added to the medium to
create axino-free culture environment
with high expansion rates of agencies
our stemx hsc expansion system
ensures high levels of cd34 plus cells
with a broad differentiation potential
and a characteristic surface phenotype
of early ages
let's have a closer look at the
expansion rate and the cd34
plus cell count in this experiment
cd34 plus cells were isolated from
cryo-preserved cord blood
using the cd34 microbead kit
then the cd-34 plus cells were expanded
for seven days in stem max
hsc expansion media or in various
commercially available alternative media
all media were supplemented with the
stem max hsc
expansion cocktail on the left side
you see the fault expansion of cd34 plus
cells
which was measured by flow cytometry our
stemx hsc
expansion system achieved an
approximately
20-fold expansion
on the right side the cd34 plus cell
content is shown
for visualization the results were
normalized to the stem max hsc expansion
system
when looking at the cd34 plus cell
content after expansion
the stem max hsc expansion system
performed consistently
among the best hsc culture systems
thus our stemx hc expansion system
provides high cd34 plus cell content
the quad blood derived cd34 plus cells
were also analyzed for the
differentiation potential
after seven days of expansion cells
cultured in the stem max hsc expansion
system
maintain a broad hematopoietic
differentiation potential
giving rise to all major colony types
including primitive cfu gems
furthermore the expanded cells were
analyzed for the surface markers
such as cd34 and cd 133 by flow
cytometry
the expanded cells in the stem max hsc
expansion system
maintained the characteristic surface
phenotype
of early hematopoietic progenitors as
shown here on the right side
taken together our stemx hsc expansion
system
ensures high levels of cd34 blast cells
with a broad differentiation potential
and a characteristic surface phenotype
of early hematopoietic progenitors
for the analysis of hscs specific
markers
are used to define the phenotype and hsc
colony essays
are used for functional analysis so
let's see
how to make your analysis of hscs smart
and easy
hscs are routinely analyzed by flow
cytometry
based on various extracellular and
intracellular markers
we at miltoni biotech offer a wide range
of unique and standard monoclonal
antibodies for research of agencies and
progenitor cells
including cd34 cd38
cd 133 and so on
our realfinity recombinant antibodies do
not require fc receptor blocking
additionally they all have the same
isotype
and therefore less isotype controls are
required
this saves time and effort our wire dye
family of fluorochromes
enables multi-color flow cytometric
analysis
with high fluorescence intensities and
low spillover
our release flurochrome technology
enables the removal of
any label after cell sorting
second i would like to shift your
attention to the functional analysis of
hses
this is performed by hsc colony firming
unit essay
short hsc cfu essay
hsc see a few essays help to examine the
ability of hscs
to proliferate and differentiate into
colonies in response to cytokine
stimulation
this is performed in vitro in the hsc
cfu
assay cells are cultured in a culture
medium supplemented with growth factors
that drive differentiation into the
mueller lineage
resulting in the outcomes of distant
colonies
the colony firming units short cf use
each cfu develops from a single founder
cell
thus the differentiation potential of
the founder cell
will determine the colony type that
develops
for the conventional hsc cfu assay
cells are cultured in semi-solid medium
this semi-solid medium is based on
material cellulose
supplemented with fbs bsa and different
growth factors our stem max hsc
cfu media are designed to maximize
growth and differentiation of progenitor
cells
and allow the single cell to grow in a
distinct colony
this is performed in a six-well plate or
35 millimeter dishes
after culture for approximately 14 days
the different colony types can be
classified by color and morphology
using a stereoscope or an inverted
microscope
this requires training and expert
knowledge
for example a cfu gem has a compact
area that is usually central to a
peripheral flat lawn of translucent
cells
that may be either large or small
therefore it is also known as the fried
egg appearance
a bfue is typically found as a three to
eight
densely packed clusters the color of
hemoglobin containing cells
ranges from dark red orange to brownish
a cfum is a sparsely growing and flat
colony
consisting of less than 20 translucent
large cells
a cfug is a flat colony consisting of 20
to 40 translucent small cells
with a germy native center a cfugm
is again a flat colony consisting of 20
to 50 translucent small
and large cells
so the identification of the different
colony types based on visual scoring
wire microscopy
is not that easy right
today i want to introduce you our
remarkable
user independent hsc cfu essay
as it takes this guesswork out of your
conventional hsc cfu essay
the user independent stem max hsc cfusa
kit
combines differentiation in meteor
cellulose free medium
with the flow cytometric readout
providing clear results
the essay is performed in round bottom
96 well plates in a liquid culture
environment
the medium of the stem max hsc cfu sa
kip
corresponds to the composition of
material cellulose-based
hsc cfu medium however
as mentioned it does not contain mature
cellulose
after culture for approximately 14 days
the different colony types are then
analyzed by flow cytometry
with specific markers this flow
cytometric readout is used for colony
counting
and identification of the different
colony types
as example any colony which exhibits at
least 15 percent of cd15 positive
15 of city 14 positive and
20 of city 235 a positive event
would be a cfu gem all other colony
types i identified in a similar way
so how does the experiment set up looks
for the stem max
hsc cfusa kit first the cells are
diluted in stem max hsc
cfusa media and then plated in a round
bottom 96 well plate
the stem max hsc cfusa media
is supplemented with growth factors as
the conventional media
which drive the differentiation into the
murelid lineage resulting in colony
formation
so after proliferation and
differentiation for 14 days
the generated colonies are stained with
the stem max
hsc cfu sa coctel followed by flow
cytometry
for the flow cytometric analysis the
first step
is the gating strategy for the performed
staining for cd15
cd14 and cd 235
a first all acquired cells needs to be
gated
as shown here in a for that use a
forward scatter versus side scatter plot
to set a gate that excludes debris and
includes all cells
then open the events of this gate on a
new plot
as shown here in b and set a new gate
that displays only single events
then you have to display the single
cells in two new plots
for that find a well with cd 235
a positive events on the first plot in
c adjust the y axis to the
channel and the x axis to the cd 235
ape channel on the second plot in c
adjust the y axis to the cd15 apc
channel
and the x axis to cd14 via blue channel
afterwards you have to set a quadrant to
separate the populations as shown here
in b
once the gates are set the same gates
can be applied for all samples
the most important information on these
plots are the percentages
of cd14 cd15 and cd235a
positive events which are displayed on
each square trend
according to the percentages the colony
type is identified
so how are the different colony types
identified
here again you see the two already
mentioned plots
the plot on the top shows the city 235a
versus cd15 and the one on the bottom
cd14 versus 3d 15.
as mentioned the most important
information
on these plots are the percentages of
cd14
cd15 and cd235a
positive events
if over 50 of positive events are
measured for cd 235
a it is a bfue colony
by getting more than 50 percent of
positive events for cd15
it is a cfug colony
a cfum colony shows over 50 percent of
positive
events for cd14 any well
which exhibits at least 30 percent
positive events for cd14
and ct thirty percent for cd15
would be as ufugm
a cfu gem is identified if a well
exhibits at least 20 of positive events
for cd 235a
15 for cd15 and 15
for cd14
here i show you some exemplary plots for
the different colony types
the percentages of cd15 cd14
and cd235a positive events
are displayed on each quadrant
the bfue shows cd 235 a
positive events at least 50 percent
the cfug sells cd15 positive events
again at least 50 percent
the cfum shows cd14 positive events
also at least 50 percent
the cfugm exhibits at least 30 percent
positive events for cd15
and 30 for cd14
finally the cfu gem has at least 15
positive events for cd15 15
for cd14 and 20 for cd 235
a so taken together the colony type is
identified
according to the percentages of cd15
cd14 and cd235a positive events
the message percentages of each marker
are exported in an excel sheet
this can be used for straightforward
colony identification
the user independent stemmex hsc cfusa
kit
is comparable to the conventional essay
here we compared the results achieved by
stemx hsc cfu assay kit
based on flow cytometric analysis with
the conventional essay based on visual
scoring
here cd 34 plus cells were isolated from
three different sources
mobilized like phrases cord blood and
peripheral blood mononuclear cells
pbmcs the cd34 plus cells
were seeded in the media from the stem
max hsc of your essay kit
or the conventional essay after
incubation for 14 days
the generated colonies of the
conventional essay
were analyzed by visual scoring the
generated colonies of the user
independent stem max hsccfu as a kit
were stained and then analyzed with the
max quant
as you see here the distribution of the
different colony types
is highly comparable between both
methods
thus the user independent stem max htcc
of your essay kit
is comparable to the conventional essay
taken together the stem max a2cc of your
assay kit
combines an easy to handle mature
cellulose free medium
and a highly standardized analysis
compared to the conventional essay which
is based on visual scoring
the stem max hsc cfu asset kit allows a
flow cytometric readout
providing clear and user-independent
results
the analysis can be automated by using
the max current
and thus allows for high throughput
measurement
here a short summary for the functional
analysis by hsc
cfu essays the conventional hc
cfusa is performed in a six well plate
or 35 millimeter dishes
the cells are cultured in a semi-solid
culture environment
which restricts cell movement and
ensures clonogenic growth
the colonies are analyzed by visual
scoring
compared to the conventional essay the
user independent stem max hsc
cfpsa kit is performed in round bottom
96 well plates in a liquid environment
after proliferation and differentiation
the generated colonies are staten
and analyzed by flow cytometry
the flow cytometric readout is
user-independent
and provides clear results as repetition
these two plots possess a high 235 a
positive staining as you see here and as
we just learned
this is then a bfue easy right
with that i would like to summarize
first we had a look at the isolation of
hses by cd34
enrichment using our max technology
we have learned that the cd34 microbead
kit
ultra viewer is the ideal choice for low
frequency
and debris rich samples it is as easy to
use as the classic cd34 microbead kit
and also suited for all routine
applications
second we talked about how to culture
hscs in a smart and easy way
we have learned that the stem max hsc
expansion system
ensures high levels of cd34 plus cells
with a broad differentiation potential
and a characteristic surface phenotype
of early ages
finally we had a look at the analysis of
hse's
after talking about the flow cytometric
characterization of the hsc phenotype
we focused on the functional analysis
besides the conventional essay i
presented the cemex htc cfu essay kit
which convinces with easy handling a
user-independent flow cytometric readout
and clear results moreover
the flow cytometric analysis is
amendable to automation
when using the max quant instrument with
that
i'm coming to the end of my presentation
thank you very much for your attention
and now i'm looking forward to your
questions
thank you anya for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
your first
question is i am working with primitive
hscs which are cd 34 plus
and cd38 minus can i use magnetic
isolation technology
as well yes
sure you can for the magnetic isolation
of these cd34 plus cd38 minus cells
we even have a specific product called
as the cells the cd34 plus cd38 minus
cell isolation kit
this kit uses a two-step positive
selection
so that means in the first step the cd34
plus cells
are positively enriched by using cd34
multi-sort microbeads which are used to
magnetically label
all cd34 plus cells afterwards these
microbeads are then
enzymatically released again then
the isolated cd34 plus cells are labeled
with cd38
microbeads to deplete all cd38 plus
cells
in the second separation step and with
that
you are having your target cells the
cd34 plus
cd38 minor cells and nice
thing to know for you it will just take
you two hours for the isolation
so if you need more information on this
product please feel free to get in touch
with us
okay i have another question for you
here
is the medium used in your user
independent
hsc cfu assay
comparable to methyl cellulose
methyl cellulose-based medium
yes it is so the medium of the user
independence demax hsc cfo sa kit
corresponds to the composition of
material cellulose-based medium
however as mentioned the medium of the
stem-max
hsc's ufo assay kit does not contain
mature cellulose
therefore please always keep in mind to
use round bottom 96 well plates for
self-seeding
when you are performing this user
independent hsccfu essay
okay great thank you all right your next
question is
for the conventional hsc cfu assay we
require proficiency testing
to cross check for the accuracy of the
assay results
how do you perform proficiency testing
for the stem max
hsc csu essay kit
this is a very good question and also
thanks for mentioning this topic
so proficiency testing was originally
established for the conventional hsc cfu
essay kit which is based on the material
cellulose medium
the conventional essay is highly
dependent on the judgment of the person
who is doing the essay and finally doing
the visual scoring
to identify the different colony types
if researchers are unexperienced or
untrained
colony types may not be identified
correctly
and here proficiency testing is required
to cross
check for accurate results in contrast
our stemx hsc cfusa kit
is based on an objective flow cytometric
readout
to identify the different colony types
this results in a user
independent and clear colony
identification
and with that the proficiency testing
becomes redundant
okay i have one more question for you
here
how much training is required to perform
the stem max
hsc cfu advocate
this is a well a question so for the
stem hsc
cfl assay kit basic cell culture skills
are sufficient
as you have seen you should be able to
prepare a cell suspension
and to seat the cells in 96 well plates
as the sa medium is metrocellulose free
it is very easy to handle
furthermore you should be able to
perform flow cytometry
as the stem max hsc cfu as a kit
uses a flow cytometric readout to
identify the different colony types
and in my opinion that's it
thank you anya for your um presentation
or
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
maybe only a short final comment from my
site
so i really enjoyed to give you today an
insight into our smart and easy
solutions for human hematopoietic stem
cell reach
research and i hope you will benefit
from it
so if you are interested to get more
information
please feel free to contact us or your
local sales representative
so from my side thanks to everyone for
joining today's webinar
and also thank you michelle for the kind
moderation
my pleasure and thank you so much for
your time today we would also like to
thank
labyrinth and our sponsor milkme biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
elaborates will alert you via email when
it's available to replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye